hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from the world
FIFA random championship is e'en upon me
versus Wesley so and the first two of
their classical games were drawn and
then Wesley won the third classical game
and now this is Game four so nepo has
the white pieces he is trying to
equalize here and some of you said that
it's not actually classical chess it's
actually slow rapid chess I don't know I
always thought that I was taught that
everything above thirty minutes
well for example if it's less than
thirty minutes then it's then it can be
classical but if it's 30 minutes plus
let's say only an increment any sort of
increment then it can be considered
classical so this is 45 minutes plus you
get additional 15 minutes after reaching
time control move 40 I don't know I
would call this classical so if this is
indeed officially called slow rapid I've
never heard heard about it but if it is
I guess we could call a little rapid but
for the time being I'm still gonna refer
to it as classical chess so let's see
how Nippo deals with him being down down
a game in the classical time format as
you get three points for a winning in
the classical section and one and a half
point for a draw so you want to get as
many points as you can in classical a
class-four time for me so Knepper with
the white pieces opens with f4 the same
as karana did against Costin if you
remember in the previous video f4 f5 and
here
Magnus twin to f6 but Wesley doesn't
allow f5 by white so f5 by Wesley and as
usual we have a completely new game we
have C for my nap oh and now b6
preparing the Finca to the light square
Bishop b4 by nipple expanding further on
the Queen side now preparing to
fianchetto both bishops on the Queen
side Bishop to b7 and Bishop to b3 now
sorry about that we and now with ideas
with maybe c5 opening up an attack
against blacks Queen so Wesley just
takes care of that Bishop to b2 now both
of the bishops or nicely Finn Carolyn
the Queen side and g5
we have Knight to g3 and here G captures
an F for now neppo doesn't recapture
right away to allow something like Queen
g5 or orbital to g5 going after the rook
so nice the
five with ideas of picking up the this
guy later and now Queen captures ng2
neppo is giving up a lot of funds in the
opening for some rapid development which
is well Knapp was one of the more
exciting players will elite players and
the nipple playing official random well
it's it's just bound to be interesting
with Castle queenside by nepo and now
Queen captures in g1 we have rook
captures in g1 and now Knight to g6 so
nip already sacrificed two points but
his pieces are very active and Wesley
still has to figure out how to develop
some of his pieces with rook D to F one
now preparing to recapture here and now
Wesley says okay I'm gonna give you back
the pawn but I'm gonna give you back the
pawn if you ruin your pawn structure a
bit further so e captures on f3 and only
now c5 will night the c2 never brings
the the last piece into the game and the
bush of the e7 with d4 now giving yet
another pawn so Wesley captures it with
pawn captures and before and now d5
further expanding in the center hoping
to open up files to go for the for the
black King and also blocking the bishops
diagonal so with Queen side castles by
Wesley and now look back to d1 with
Bishop to c5 now attacking the rook here
putting a bishop doing much nicer
diagonal and now Knight to f6 so what's
the idea here well and never wants to
get the other root over 2g one sacrifice
the exchange pick of the the h7 point
and then well I remove the defender of
the g6 night so better characters and g1
we have rook captures and g1 and the now
rook the f7
not so much defending gauge seven point
you can't really defend the Knight
captures and rook captures than g6 will
happen but it also serves as a defender
to the d7 pawn because
neppo had some ideas of going butter up
to a for the threat in this guy here
maybe maybe even the other night can can
find its way to be five so he wants to
create some threats here we have Knight
captures on b4
now this Knight can come to the five
maybe via d3 and
and night to see seven we have night
back to be three and now look DITA FA
doubling up on the F file and only now
does nipple capture on h7 will night
captures rook captures and rook captures
on g6 we have rook captures on h2
now that's a very active rook and now d6
kicking the night away we have nice to
a6 and now Bishop to a for adding an
attacker here so maybe maybe you can get
rook to g7 and if you can get nice to e5
in then white should definitely have
some chances route back to h7 by Wesley
adding another defender to the d7 pawn
and now 95 now isn't all that great you
don't have a way of organising an attack
here because night c5 defends it nicely
also you will have to move your butcher
back so a 95 does not work in this in
this setup so Bishop to b5 by nipple and
now comes nice to see 5 all the same we
have Knight captures and c5 be
characters and f4 so taking taking the
e5 square also not allowing the pawn and
f3 to remain a target we have worked the
h1 check by Wesley King the c2 and rook
to h2 check we have King to b3 and now a
6 pushing the bishop back with Bishop to
a 4 and now Bishop to e4
grabbing more space maybe even hoping to
trade a material with Bishop to see to
check picking off the bishop on a4 with
pink to a3 and now comes Luke to g2
Wesley's up in the material so as a
principled idea when you're up in
material you want to trade down we
looked at h6 nipple of course declines
the trade and the now comes rook to g3
with check King to c1 sorry Bishop to b3
blocking check and now a 5 here a Wesley
is preparing Bishop the c6 the Guardian
for square he wants to push pawn to a4
and then pick up the bishop as you will
not be able to move it due to the pin so
Bishop to e5
making an escape route for the King also
adding another defender to the f4 pawn
here although for the moment this Bishop
basically a pawn okay you do control
this diagonal but if the black rook
wants to enter the game he can always
use the G file
Bishop the c6 now again preparing a for
to win the bishop came to b2 and here
Wesley played rock the g2 with check and
it was in this position that Ian upon
she resigned the game as he he doesn't
have all that much contra play and he is
very long time so one one such line that
we can show is you have to move the King
King to c1 and now you just push a for
you push the brush back Bishop the c2
and now you get the other rook into the
game so now you can maybe just double up
rooks on the second rank then threatened
the bishop then try to pick up the DA to
pawn for example you could try rook the
H it would wipe the get rid of one of
the rooks and then try to counter the
the remaining rook with the bishop pair
but after rook captures Bishop captures
rook to f2 first you go after this pawn
once y defends it then you play a3 don't
allow the King any any squares once
white makes a move let's say Bishop to
b2 the only square where you can move
the bishop to keep an eye on the a to
pawn so now this Bishop stuck guarding
this point is Bishop stop stuck
regarding this point and once you play
Bishop to g4 for example White is in
white is insuk's wrong there is no move
if you move this Bishop you lose this
point if you move this Bishop you lose
this pawn and if you don't move any
bishops you have to move your Kings so
you can go here here here here you can
only play King to d1 now you just play
better of the b1 pick up this pawn
either trade bishops or move your Bishop
Queen D a point and that's it so there
really is nothing more to do here even
though it might seem like there is but
but there isn't so after work - G -
check Napo resigned and Wesley wins a
game three endgame for in classical time
form it we're still gonna call it
classical for now so today we're going
into the rapid section and then of
course the next day into the blade
section so it probably should be very
exciting so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it it's gonna be very
interesting to see who comes up on top
Magnus or Caruana or in this case nipple
or Wesley so I would also like to thank
georgeanna bronzy not all Mohamed
matheus Mossman a coral Nielson and
Alexander Kovalenko for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as you
you can check to my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
soon continuing the coverage of the
world fish random Championship
continuing the short coverage of the
22nd European Team Championship and of
course checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest
early